as children return to school remotely or
in person there is a growing concern
about their mental and emotional health
last may 29 percent of parents surveyed
said their child was experiencing harm
to their emotional
or mental health because of social
distancing and closures
for our school matters series meg oliver
spoke to a new jersey family
struggling with the changes did you ever
feel like you were depressed
a few times eleven-year-old rocco testa
will be a sixth grader in little falls
new jersey this fall
over the last few months like many kids
the pandemic took a toll on his mental
health
it was just me being angry at the world
and everything because
because of covid and stuff you were
angry at the world
how did that feel it just felt like
like i just wanted to punch something
rocco has adhd and some learning
difficulties
which made virtual school challenging as
his great slipped he began
lashing out gina testa is his mom did
you recognize rocco anymore
no he got that back it got that bad
virtual learning
has been a huge huge blow to him
to his academics and his mental health
and not having the support and the
teachers there to help him
has been just detrimental
rocco who is type 1 diabetes is now
dealing with depression and anxiety
how hard is that for a mother to see
your 11 year old depressed
it's unspeakable it's something i never
thought i'd ever have to
to do the testa family is not alone at
the end of the school
year nearly three in 10 parents reported
their child's mental health was
suffering due to social distancing
and closures we're seeing increases in
anxiety
there have been increases in calls to
suicide and mental health
hotlines kathleen minke is the executive
director of the national association of
school psychologists
she said parents should look for warning
signs like changes in their child's
behavior
energy levels difficulty sleeping or
eating or
disinterest in previous enjoyable
activities
what's the most important question
parents should ask their children every
day
how are you doing what happened today
that was
good for you and really giving just
giving kids the space to say what they
want to say
minke said it's not just the pandemic
currently affecting kids mental health
there are
problems with racism and violence and so
you really have a piling up
of stressors for many many kids why is
it so important to train
about children's mental health before
you go back
if the student is not in a good place
socially emotionally they're not going
to be able to learn
nikki wong xing is a guidance counselor
in the school district of philadelphia
how bad did it get for some of your
students in terms of their mental health
issues
last spring what i saw happen a lot is
this feeling of isolation
some stress too there were family
members that lost their job
and then some of the kids with things
that were happening with the black lives
matter movement and george floyd and
that's really hard because we weren't
there to kind of help them through that
process
the district launched a program called
healing together
it focuses on four areas social
emotional learning
mental health and trauma relationships
and community and adult wellness
the program provides resources workshops
and support for students staff
and families back in new jersey rocco is
starting to feel better
he's playing football again and he
regularly meets with his school
psychologist
what's your advice for other kids that
might be feeling the same way when you
like feel angry just take a second
and walk away i know that we're not
unique and people need to know that
this didn't just affect our economy and
all these other things
it affected our kids and their minds and
their minds and their mental health
for cbs this morning meg oliver little
falls new jersey
boy you really feel for rocco's mom
there and for rocco and
the hard part of this is is there's
there's stress on the parents too even
before this
yeah oh you know and uh everybody's
feeling and i i'm everybody i talk to is
feeling
yeah we always talk about kids being
resilient but this is a really big test
of that resilience
that's why i appreciate rocco very cute
kid by the way very cute rocco you are
and
i appreciate rocco and his family
sharing the story publicly
with everybody because this is hard to
talk about and him saying what he said
today will only help others
it's so important to talk about it bravo
what's really interesting in all this
and i've heard this from my wife the
teacher who i talk about a lot is yeah
some kids respond really well to being
at home and remote learning and for some
it's a
huge challenge and it changes everything
as we saw with rocco